die stärke einer landeswährung hängt von
der stärke der landwirtschaft ab in
amerika hat mit abstand die stärkste
wirtschaft der welt
folglich habe ich den finanzminister
angewiesen die nötigen schritte zu
ergreifen um den dollar vor spekulanten
zu schützen
in kanada wurde angewiesen vorübergehend
die ein tausch barkeit des dollars in
gold oder andere reserve werte
aufzuheben sofern die mengen und
bedingungen nicht der finanziellen
stabilität und den interessen der
vereinigten staaten dienlich sind
der fünfzehnte august 1971 wird noch für
viele generationen ein entscheidendes
ereignis der wirtschaftsgeschichte seien
selbst in hunderten von jahren wird man
sich noch daran erinnern
[Musik]
das auch heute geht die sonne auf die
schon millionenfach zuvor pendler wachen
auf und fahren ins büro um ihr tagwerk
zu verrichten
landwirte kümmern sich um die ernte und
bauarbeiter errichten neue infrastruktur
es ist ein tag wie jeder andere
oder nicht 2008 erlebte die welt eines
der größten wirtschafts leben aller
zeiten
weltweit brachen die märkte ein und
finanzinstitutionen die einst als
unangreifbar galten drohten in sich
zusammenzufallen kollaps regierungen
reagierten schnellen und beschlossen
rettungs und konjunkturpakete um die
weltwirtschaft über wasser zu halten
mit erfolg die globale wirtschaft
erholte sich viel schneller als die
meisten erwarteten und alles war wieder
wie zuvor
doch stimmt etwas nicht ganz die unruhe
in der bevölkerung in der finanzwelt
wenn nicht gar in allen bereichen des
modernen lebens tun sich risse auf
[Musik]
viele haben angst wenn man die menschen
auf der straße fragt wissen sie zwar
nicht was genau los ist
aber sie spüren dass etwas nicht stimmt
die regierung macht verluste in
millionenhöhe
warum wächst die wirtschaft nicht wieder
die regierung gibt fast 3,7 billionen
dollar aus warum habe ich keine arbeit
warum liegt die arbeitslosigkeit bei 9
prozent wenn nicht sogar höher
viele in der heutigen welt sind
verunsichert und besorgt dass etwas
schreckliches bevorstehen könnte es
heißt die weltfinanzkrise von vor ein
paar jahren sei überwunden
was aber wenn die krise nicht einfach
nur die ursache unserer angst war
sondern symptom eines viel tiefer
greifenden problems
in bretton woods die helmschale treffen
die delegierten aus 44 ländern der
alliierten zur eröffnung der un
finanzkonferenz 1
die geschichte beginnt 1944 am ende des
zweiten weltkriegs trafen sich die
alliierten in bretton woods new
hampshire um ein neues finanzsystem zu
etablieren und die welt in der
nachkriegszeit zu stabilisieren da man
ein goldenes zeitalter für die usa
erwartet wurde der us dollar zur
leitwährung ernannt das bretton woods
system wurde nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
bei der konferenz in bretton woods
erschaffen
anstatt gold als tausch medium zwischen
ländern zu verwenden wie es beim vorigen
goldstandard der fall war entschied man
sich den dollar zu verwenden denn der
war damals so gut wie gott in diesem
neuen system wurde für jede
landeswährung ein fester wechselkurs zum
dollar bestimmt
der dollar war mit einem festen preis
von 35 dollar pro unze an gold somit
konnten alle länder der welt ihre
währung in dollar und diese dann in gold
umwandeln
dadurch waren letztlich in diesem system
alle währungen durch gold gedeckt
um das physische gold nicht über den
globus verschicken zu müssen wurde das
gold in dass andere länder ihre
währungen eintauschten zumeist sicher in
den usa verwahrt
unter dem bretton-woods-system konnten
andere länder und zentralbanken ihre
währungen und dollar in gold umtauschen
dann fingen die haushaltsdefizite an das
great society programm von lyndon
johnson der krieg in vietnam
plötzlich waren wir - und die anderen
länder gaben ihre dollar ab und wollten
dort zuerst frankreich dann immer mehr
in anbetracht der wachsenden ausgaben
befürchteten andere länder die usa
könnten mehr geld ausgeben als ihre
goldreserven abdecken
sie tauschten ihre dollar in gold und
verlangten physische gold lieferungen da
sie vermuteten es würden mehr dollar
gedruckt als gold vorhanden war um die
abwanderung des goldes aus den usa suren
zu unterbinden
dies präsident nixon den umtausch in
gold aussetzen
ich habe ich den finanzminister
angewiesen die nötigen schritte zu
ergreifen um den dollar vor spekulanten
zu schützen
minister karl wurde angewiesen
vorübergehend die ein tausch barkeit des
dollars in gold oder andere reserve
werte aufzuheben
alle probleme unseres aktuellen
finanzsystems sind direkte folgen der
entscheidung vom 15
august 1971 die feste verbindung zum
gold auf zu kennen gold zwang
regierungen zur disziplin und zur
mäßigung ihrer ausgaben hatte man im
alten system ein haushaltsdefizit wurde
solange gold ausgeführt bis das
gleichgewicht wieder hergestellt war
ohne die abdeckung durch gold sind
staaten nun dauerhaft im defizit die usa
zum beispiel hatten seit 1971 keinen
haushaltsüberschuss mehr zeit wir vom
goldstandard weg sind hatten wir
durchgehend konjunktur defizite in guten
wie in schlechten zeiten
nixon 1971 den goldstandard auf
angeblich nur vorübergehend aber wir
warten noch immer auf die
wiedereinführung
wir machten in den 60ern massive
verluste aufgrund der ganzen wirtschaft
bei der die regierung zum einen krieg in
vietnam führte und zum anderen bemannte
mondmissionen und das raumfahrtprogramm
finanzierte mussten wir mehr geld
drucken als unsere goldreserven zuließen
viele unserer ausländischen kreditgeber
sahen das und verlangten gold anstatt
der banknoten der federal reserve
weil sie spürten dass washington nicht
genug gold haben würde und das
wertversprechen des dollars einzuhalten
indem er die verbindung zum gold-cup
erschuf präsident nixon ein system in
dem alle währungen durch nichts gedeckt
waren
man spricht hierbei von fiat währungen
vier währungen sind durch nichts außer
versprechen von regierungen gedeckt fiat
kommt aus dem lateinischen es ist also
geld das durch zwang im umlauf ist
wenn die menschen der währung vertrauen
und der regierung genug macht hat bleibt
die währung eine weile lang im umlauf
bis die menschen das vertrauen wieder
verlieren
kein land der welt verwendet aktuell
tatsächliches geld wir alle nutzen wir
irgendwann werden wir alle den
unterschied erkennen
geld ist ein austausch medium
es war dabei immer etwas das von sich
aus werth hatte bis zur moderne
politiker sagen wir brauchen nichts
wertvolles mehr wir brauchen nur
politische entscheidungen
wir sagen einfach dieses stück papier
wäre geld jetzt hat geld eine neue
eigenschaft aber grundsätzlich gilt das
gleiche konzept dass niemand
anzuzweifeln wagt nämlich dass
regierungen das recht haben etwas an
sich wertloses zu geld zu erklären
und dass man das zu akzeptieren habe das
ist ein problem und es zerstört auch
heute noch die weltwirtschaft
verwirrungen nicht mehr durch echte
werte gedeckt sind wie misst sich ihr
wert nur noch im verhältnis zueinander
länder mit schwachen währungen können
produkte günstig herstellen also
entwerten sie ihre währungen gezielt um
als handelspartner attraktiver zu werden
jede papierwährung vergleicht sich mit
dem dollar sinkt der dollar reagieren
die zentralbanken anderer länder und
schreiten auf dem währungsmarkt ein
damit die auswirkungen ihre wirtschaft
nicht beeinträchtigen
was ist ein ponzi system ein ponzi
system ist ein betrügerisches investment
angebot dass investoren große gewinne
bei keinem oder geringem risiko
verspricht gegen zu gut um wahr zu sein
stimmt bei seriösen investment modellen
wird das geld zur wertschöpfung in
risikoarme anlage werte wie aktien oder
immobilien portfolios investiert mit
derzeit generiert dies genug einkommen
um die investition zuzüglich eines
profis zurückzuzahlen ein poldersystem
verspricht jedoch gewaltige gewinne in
kürzester zeit wie funktioniert das
anstatt das geld sinnvoll zu investieren
werden bei einem pool system einfach
mehr investoren gewonnen
um die vorigen investoren auszuzahlen da
die neuen investoren auch große gewinne
versprochen wurden muss anschließend
eine noch größere gruppe gefunden werden
um sie zu bezahlen
während die initiatoren einen teil des
geldes jeder gruppe für sich behalten
da das conti system selbst keine wert
generiert wissen kontinuierlich immer
größere investorengruppen hinten gezogen
werden damit es weiter funktioniert
irgendwann findet man keine neuen
investoren mehr oder eine große anzahl
der bisherigen investoren sich
zeitgleich auszahlen lassen wodurch das
system zusammenbricht
zu dem zeitpunkt haben die initiatoren
gewaltige beträge für sich beiseite
geschafft und die investoren haben keine
gewinne sondern pech gehabt
ohne feste verbindung zum gold konnte
die us staatskasse beliebig viel geld
leihen und ausgeben und braucht die
us-regierung geld leiht sie es sich von
der us-notenbank notenbank druckt ii für
das darlehen erforderlichen banknoten
und bekommt von der staatskasse einen
schuldschein die schuldscheine nennt man
staatsanleihen mit dem geld dieser
darlehen oder anleihen bezahlt die us
regierung ihre rechnungen und
verpflichtungen zeitgleich versteigern
die us staatskasse und die notenbank
diese anleihen gemeinsam bei auktionen
zu ausländische zentralbanken
rentenfonds und auch einzelpersonen in
diese us staatsanleihen kaufen
warum auch nicht der us-regierung geld
zu leihen war seit jeher eine sichere
investition wenn die darlehen jedoch für
rechnungen und die auszahlung frühere
anleihen genutzt werden woher bekommt
die regierung das geld und die aktuellen
anleihen mit zinsen zurückzuzahlen ist
die investition in anleihen der us
regierung letztlich teil eines
gewaltigen panzer systems das system der
us-notenbank ist ein panzer system ganz
ohne zweifel
sie geben vor der regierung geld zu
leihen und die regierung sagt zu das
geld mit zinsen zurückzuzahlen
das geld wird tatsächlich erst für genau
diesen zweck erschaffen und der
regierung gegeben
vorher existierte es gar nicht sind hall
banken erschaffen es aus dem nichts mit
ein paar computer klicks erschaffen sie
eine billion dollar die die staatskasse
die regierung nun ausgeben kann so
einfach entsteht das geld die us
regierung ist nun aber verpflichtet das
geld mit zinsen zurückzuzahlen
die zinsen darf man nicht vergessen wenn
sie es zurückzahlen müssen können sie
das nicht schon gar nicht mit zinsen
also leihen sie sich einfach noch mehr
geld um die ursprünglichen kredite mit
zinsen zu bezahlen
der kongress will dann sowieso mehr geld
und der schuldenberg wächst und wächst
und wächst im aktuellen währungssystem
entsteht unser geld dadurch dass wir es
uns laien und versprechen es mit zinsen
zurück zu bezahlen wenn der erste und
einzige dollar der welt dadurch entsteht
dass man ihn sich leid und dann mit
einem dollar zinsen zurückzahlen will
woher kommt der zweite dollar man muss
ihn natürlich leyen
es ist ein ponzi system da man die
schulden abbezahlen kann und immer mehr
anhäufen
seit 1971 haben die usa ein
handelsdefizit im verhältnis zur übrigen
welt
wir kaufen also viel mehr produkte von
ihnen als sie insgesamt von uns kaufen
japan und korea verkaufen uns autos und
elektroartikel der nahe osten verkauft
uns in china verkauft uns gefühlt das
ganze supermarkt angebot die usa zahlen
dafür in us-dollar und alle sind
zufrieden habe aber würden die länder
diese dollar gewinne in ihre eigenen
währungen konvertieren würden diese an
wert gewinnen und das land würde als
handelspartner weniger attraktiv
stattdessen investieren diese länder
ihre dollar gewinne in us staatsanleihen
die länder der welt verkaufen ihre waren
an die usa im austausch für us dollar
die von der us notenbank gegen
schuldscheine geliehen wurden
dann nein die länder den usa ihre dollar
gewinne zurück indem sie ihrerseits
schuldschein erwerb das geld dieser
darlehen wird zur begleichung von
rechnungen und zur auszahlung früherer
kredite verwendet
dafür müssen aber immer größere kredite
aufgenommen werden um die geliehenen
beträge mit zinsen zurückzuzahlen
der alte darlehen durch neue größere
darlehen zurückgezahlt werden wirkt es
als würde die ganze welt ihr geld in ein
ponzi system epischen ausmaßes
investieren
wenn bei diesem geschäft der geld her
stellung für regierungen hier und
überall auf der welt nicht mehr und mehr
geld generiert würde welche das ganze in
sich zusammen
denn es sind schließlich die neuen
schulden mit denen die alten schulden
beglichen werden es ist ein ganz
klassisches panzer system damit die us
wirtschaft funktioniert müssen wir uns
mehr und mehr geld von anderen ländern
ein
je mehr sie uns heute leyen desto mehr
müssen sie uns in zukunft live hören sie
irgendwann auf damit bricht alles
zusammen und wir können sie nicht
zurückbezahlt jeden freitagabend
vergleicht julia die preise der lokalen
supermärkte für ihren samstagmorgen ein
kauf es gibt fünf märkte in den blogs um
unser haus und julia kauft alles dort wo
die preise am niedrigsten und die
qualität am höchsten ist eine
tankfüllung filmstar eine sechsköpfige
familie aß für 35 dollar pro woche was
ist seitdem geschehen ohne greifbare
grundlage für währungen konnten
regierungen so viel geld drucken wie sie
wollten
das hat den wert unserer währung nach
und nach untergraben die erschaffung all
dieses geldes verringert den wert der
bestehenden dollar immer mehr wodurch
die kaufkraft immer weiter sinkt eine
gallone benzin kostete mal 31 cent
jetzt sind es etwa fünf dollar der
normalverbraucher erlebt inflation als
verringerte kaufkraft dadurch sinkt sein
lebensstandard wenn er nicht mit der
inflationsrate schritt halten kann
in vielen bereichen ist der
lebensstandard in amerika heute
schlechter nehmen wir meine großeltern
als beispiel meine großmutter musste nie
arbeiten obwohl mein großvater nur
schreiner waren sie acht kinder hatten
könnte ein schreiner ein arbeiter im
handwerk ohne high school abschluss
heute eine frau und acht kinder
finanzieren
keine chance
da die inflation schneller stieg als das
einkommen musste der lebensstandard mit
immer drastischeren maßnahmen erhalten
werden
jeden tag beginnt die arbeit der familie
von 9
bevor wir den dollar von gold renten
gegen üblicherweise der man arbeiten und
die frau kümmerte sich um haus und
familie in den siebzigern arbeitete die
frau dann aufgrund der inflation auch
man braucht er also zwei einkommen um
die gleichen waren und dienstleistungen
zu bezahlen
in den neunzigern hörten wir aufzusparen
die sparquote spiel nahezu auf null
man musste das geld ausgeben um die
gleichen waren und dienste zu kaufen und
konnte nicht sparen dann in den 2000
die frau arbeitete schon ersparnisse
waren auf null also lieh man geht
wir brauchten also erst zwei einkommen
müssten aufhören zu sparen und zuletzt
geld leihen um mit der inflation schritt
zu halten
der durchschnittsverbraucher sieht sich
nun gezwungen geld zu leihen und
verschuldet sich dadurch erheblich hat
zuerst diese dies der aufrechterhaltung
eines gehobenen lebensstandard
doch mittlerweile ist es allein für das
überleben erforderlich es scheint als
würden regierungen in dem sie mehr und
mehr geld trocken und ihre währung
entwerten ihrem volk eine verdeckte
zusatzsteuer auferlegen zentralbanken
behaupten zwei oder drei prozent
inflation wären etwas gutes
erstrebenswert sogar es sind aber
steuern
wieso sind zwei oder drei prozent
inflation besser für das land als keine
inflation
es heißt dann immer das sei besser als
deflation und dass den menschen das
gefühl gefällt ihr einkommen würde um
ein paar prozent steigen das wäre doch
etwas gutes
tatsächlich wird ihnen jedoch geld
gestohlen und ihr effektives einkommen
sinkt wir erleben derzeit inflation
angeblich steigt der vp um zwei oder
drei prozent
aber es fehlt doch jedem auf dass die
inflation viel größer ist womöglich
sogar zweistellig kaufkraft des
durchschnittsbürgers schrumpft
dramatisch
um dies zu verbergen verzerren
regierungen jedoch die daten ihrer
berichte damit die inflation viel
kleiner wirkt als sie tatsächlich ist
es gibt diese befindliche unterscheidung
zwischen kerninflation und
gesamtinflation die viele nicht
verstehen
die kerninflation ist diese zielwert von
2 prozent nicht weiter wichtig die
gesamtinflation berücksichtigt auch
dinge wie energiepreise plötzliche
steuererhöhungen und dergleichen
die inflationsrate ist verzerrt man
nutzt allerlei ausflüchte um sie
geringer erscheint so lang
als sie ist würde die regierung den vdi
genauso berechnen wie damals unter
präsident carter in den späten 70ern
wäre die inflationsrate in den usa heute
neun oder zehn so sehr wird die währung
entwertet der grund dafür sind die
vielen inflationsbereinigten
verpflichtungen der us regierung
so sind zum beispiel hilfszahlungen im
sozialsystem inflationsbereinigt und an
diese angepasst wenn sie die
inflationsrate in den offiziellen
statistiken klein halten müssen sie
weniger zahlen unter staatsdefizit sinkt
poletto lido ist eines der größten
zentren für die glasverarbeitung geht es
hingegen primär um gummi gummi
herstellungs- hauptstadt des landes
sogar der welt grün steht für gummi in
einer welt in der währungen nur in
relation zueinander bewertet werden kann
können staaten den wert ihrer währung
künstlich verringern und ihrer industrie
so einen wettbewerbsvorteil verschaffen
ein land mit einer schwachen währung
kein produkte billiger herstellen
denn so für die internationale
verlagerung ganzer industriezweige
worden dies ließ sich zahllose male in
städten auf der ganzen welt beobachtet
einige davon haben sich immer noch nicht
vom verlust ihrer industrie erholt
die menschen sind verzweifelt
sie haben studiert haben keine arbeit
finden keine arbeit müssen studenten
kredite bezahlen haben erhöhte
lebenshaltungskosten
die fährt sagt es gebe keine inflation
aber man sieht doch wie die preise für
eier milch und fleisch im laden steigen
die spritpreise an der tankstelle
steigen auch man versteht nicht wie sehr
der einzelne betroffen ist darum sind
sie frustriert denn es wird einem
nirgendwo beigebracht das geld zu
drucken ohne dass es gedeckt ist die
währung entwertet und all diese
nebenwirkungen hervorruft die wir
beobachten steigende inflation kosten
korruption günstlingswirtschaft
all das hat in den letzten jahren
schlagzeilen gemacht
protestbewegungen sind ein interessantes
phänomen
viele menschen sind fürchterlich wütend
auf die wall street auf das was mit
ihrer kaufkraft geschieht
sie sind wütend darüber dass sie in den
nachrichten erfahren die manager dieser
banken bekämen boni in millionenhöhe
während sie gleichzeitig dem
steuerzahler im rahmen der bankenrettung
auf der tasche liegen
ja das macht sie wütend leider
demonstrieren die menschen zwar gegen
die wirtschaftskrise fordern aber
gleichzeitig mehr sozialhilfe staatliche
krankenversicherungen mehr staatliche
kontrolle und regulierung dass mir geld
erschaffen und in die gesellschaft
gesteckt werden soll und bemerken dabei
jedoch nicht dass diese dinge die wahre
ursache sind warum sie wütend auf die
straße gehen
während der einzelne nur mit mühe über
die runden kommt erzählt man uns es sei
eine normale rezession session
warum aber fühlt sich diese krise dann
anders an als vorangegangene rezessionen
das ist alles andere als normal
es ist viel eher das ändern wir erleben
den todeskampf unseres 40-jährigen
experiments mit fiat währungen welches
in einem absoluten fehlschlag in amerika
ebenso wie überall auf der welt bis 2018
wir uns mehr und mehr geld um unseren
lebensstandard zu erhalten haben wir nun
das maximum erreicht und können keine
weiteren schulden aufnehmen
heute findet in allen
gesellschaftsschichten ein schuldenabbau
statt die verbraucher sind am limit
jedes mal wenn wir den zyklus von
höhenflug und pleite durchlaufen haben
wurde mit der pleite die im nächste
inflation losgetreten in die wirtschaft
anzukurbeln
wodurch jedes mal mehr und mehr schulden
angehäuft worden
jetzt ist der punkt erreicht an dem wir
keine schulden mehr machen können banken
gewähren kredite nicht mehr so
leichtfertig wie zuvor
viele bürger sind damit beschäftigt alte
schulden abzubezahlen anstatt neue
schulden aufzunehmen
das ist zum einen vorsichtig und
vernünftig zum anderen eine bedrohung
für die weltwirtschaft als gewaltiges
pons dieses team ist die weltwirtschaft
für ihren fortbestand darauf angewiesen
dass immer mehr und immer größere
schulden angehäuft werden wenn wir nicht
über unsere verhältnisse leben und
versuchen mit dem geld das wir haben
auszukommen
bricht die währungs versorgung durch die
zinsen in sich zusammen darum müssen wir
weiterhin jeden monat mehr dollar
erschaffen und uns laien als wir in
schulden abbauen kann
so wie das system aktuell aufgestellt
ist muss die geldversorgung konstant
ausgeweitet werden damit das system
nicht untergeht politiker und
kommentatoren predigen ein gemäßigtes
leben und die begleichung der schulden
dadurch würde aber die wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen sie würde regelrecht
verschwinden alle politiker sind in der
zwickmühle wenn sie nicht zur rettung
einbricht über nacht alles zusammen
und das wäre niemand so lange an der
macht ist darum wollen alle die
verantwortung weiter geben und lassen
den kelch quasi an sich vorüber ziehen
es ist aber das ende der fahnenstange
erreicht wir können den kelchen
niemanden mehr weitergeben und müssen
selbst damit fertig werden was mit jedem
mai als er weitergegeben wurde
schwieriger wurde es ist ein großes
erdrückendes problem geworden
die finanzkrise von 2008 macht das erste
vorzeichen vom ende des konzerts systems
gewesen sein
doch regierungen auf der ganzen welt
machten keine anstalten es einfach
untergehen zu lassen also verzögerten
sie das unvermeidliche durch die rettung
maroder finanzinstitutionen
sie kauften faule hypotheken und namen
im namen des volkes schulden auf 2009
und 2010 wurde die krise einfach
überbrückt indem man banken rettete und
stetig neues geld druckt und ins system
punkte man sollte nicht vergessen dass
regierungen auf kurze sicht ergebnisse
einfach erzwingen können langfristig
wurden die probleme aber nicht gelöst
die schulden sind noch da die banken
sind noch immer insolvent und bessern
sich nicht die wirtschaft stagniert
nichts wurde gelöst
indem sie sich immer wieder freikaufen
gelb truppen das system damit überfluten
und die kaufkraft verwässern lösen sie
das problem nicht
sie schieben es nur ein wenig auf und
machen es noch schlimmer machen wir nun
also einfach so weiter und trocken mehr
geld die bilanz der fed wuchs schon von
800 milliarden auf 3 millionen sollen es
jetzt sechs millionen werden kommt nach
dem 800 milliarden konjunkturpaket 1 mit
zwei billionen
das könnte man schon machen aber so
würde die währung mangels vertrauen
womöglich einbrechen der offene geldhahn
der us notenbank stützt die wirtschaft
kurzfristig durchaus doch was sind die
folgen wenn man in diesem maßstab
einfach geld druckt ich erwarte dass der
wert des dollars sehr schnell einbrechen
wird
innerhalb weniger tage ob nun um 20 30
oder 40 prozent
viele flüchten sich zur sicherheit in
den dollar
was wenn sie nun merken dass es hier gar
keine sicherheit gibt und dass sie aus
dem dollar fliehen müssen der aktuell
von der angst profitiert was wenn die
menschen in den dollar fürchten
zusätzlich zur gewaltigen inflation
besteht auch das risiko dass die
us-notenbank indem sie weiterhin
leichtfertig geld druckt das globale
vertrauen in den us-dollar erschüttern
könnte
eine währungskrise halte ich für sehr
wahrscheinlich
was genau sie wann verursachen wird ist
schwer vorherzusagen
vielleicht kommt sie überraschend durch
eine naturkatastrophe einen politischen
schock oder einfach durch
vertrauensverlust da würde schon eine
einfache option des finanzministeriums
reichen die mangels käufern scheitert
durch die zinsen steigen dann reagieren
die großen hedgefonds und stoßen ihre
dollar gefolgt von ausländischen
zentralbanken die aus dem dollar
flüchten und schon ist es passiert
wie bei jedem pons system erkennen die
teilnehmer irgendwann wie der hase läuft
und wollen aussteigen wodurch alles in
sich zusammenfällt wenn private und
freiwillige teilnehmer also private
investoren und ausländische
zentralbanken nicht mehr weiter greifen
kann die notenbank einschreiten und die
forderungen gera die aus dem pool system
aussteigen wo erfüllen wenn die
us-notenbank dann aber der einzige
verbleibende käufer ist ist das ende der
fahnenstange erreicht und die
hyperinflation bekennt hyperinflation
ist ein derart schnelle anstieg der
inflationsrate dass die menschen das
vertrauen in die währung verlieren was
dann auch zur währungs luft führt
galoppierende inflation im besiegten
deutschland die mark ist so wertlos
geworden dass man sie als tapete oder
zum anheizen des ofens verwendet die
regierung sieht sich also gezwungen so
viel geld auszugeben und zu leihen dass
der markt irgendwann nicht mehr gewillt
ist entsprechende mengen zu verleihen
dann schreitet die zentralbank ein und
verwandelt die schulden in neue währung
die große frage wobei ich die antwort
selbst nicht kenne
bei wievielen inflation 5 10 15 20
beginnt die panik wenn es soweit ist
werden aber sicherlich alle in panik
verfallen
infolge einer hyperinflation steigen die
preise für waren und dienstleistungen
rapide wodurch die menschen sich ihrer
währung noch schneller entledigen
dann fangen die leute an waren zu kaufen
nur um ihr papier geld loszuwerden
das treibt die nachfrage nach papiergeld
paradoxerweise noch weiter an weil man
ja damit einkaufen werden somit sinkt
der wert des papiers noch bevor es in
umlauf kommt im alltag wird man nach
kräften greifbare dinge bekommen fallen
statt einer dose thunfisch kauft man
dann frei man weiß ja dass die gleiche
dose morgen oder vielleicht sogar schon
später am gleichen tag mehr kosten wird
man holt alles was irgendwie greifbar
ist
das wird mit einem großen
wirtschaftlichen leid einhergehen
viele ruheständler in amerika werden
sich arbeit suchen müssen weil ihre
altersvorsorge sich plötzlich in luft
aufgelöst hat
sie haben sich auf ein nationales
punktesystem in bester bernie madoff
manier verlassen
auch immobilien werden verfallen da die
menschen zuerst ihre unmittelbaren
bedürfnisse decken müssen und kein geld
für reparaturen und instandhaltungen
haben werden wenn vermieter keine miete
mehr bezahlt bekommen wie sollen sie die
immobilien erhalten und steuern seien
die ganze wirtschaft wird von der last
der installation erdrückt werden
die erste reaktion der notenbank wird
natürlich sein noch mehr inflation zu
verursachen indem sie die wirtschaft mit
noch mehr neuem geld anzukurbeln
versuchen was ja eigentlich die wurzel
des problems ist auf den ersten blick
scheint dieses problem nur die usa zu
betreiben
da aber so viele länder ihre rücklagen
in form von us-anleihen lagern könnte
ein vertrauensverlust des dollars eine
globale krise auslösen
die sämtliche länder der erde betreffen
würde eine hyperinflation des dollars
hätte weitreichende folgen
die auswirkungen einer hyperinflation
lassen sich in ländern wie simbabwe
beobachten was passiert aber wenn die
globale leitwährung hyperinflation
erfährt das hatten wir noch nicht und
die folgen sind unmöglich vorherzusagen
die logische folge einer hyperinflation
des dollars wären massive
wirtschaftliche probleme für alle
anderen währungen der welt da die
reserven all dieser währungen letztlich
in dollar liegen
[Musik]
seit dem ende des zweiten weltkrieges
sind dutzende währungen untergegangen
und die ursache war immer die gleiche
schlechte politische entscheidungen
aktuell treffen die usa schlechte
politische entscheidungen und die
zentralbank verwaltet die währung auch
nicht gut
der untergang des dollars ist somit
unausweichlich wir sind auf dem weg zum
friedhof der fiat währungen der markt
die privatwirtschaft die menschen wären
plötzlich verstehen was los ist dann
beginnt der herren treten
das kann über nacht passieren wann es
passiert ist für uns nahezu unmöglich
vorherzusagen
aber es besteht immer das risiko dass
wir eines morgens aufwachen und uns in
einer gänzlich anderen welt wiederfinden
vielleicht nicht über eine nacht sondern
eine woche oder einen monat aber wenn es
so weit ist wird es schnell gehen ohne
dass sie es vorher sehen können
inflation ist nur eines der szenarien
die die welt heute bedrohen
die geschichte lehrt uns jedoch dass
jede nation die ihre wirtschaft auf ein
künstliches fiat system stützt das
gleiche schicksal ereilt unheil die
quote der fehlschläge liegt nachweislich
bei 100 prozent fiat währungen scheitern
immer vor 40 jahren begann dann das
große experiment bei dem alle währungen
mit dem ende des bretton woods systems
gleichzeitig zu viert währungen wurden
die welt muss einen ausweg aus diesem
dollar basierten währungssystem finden
eine währung braucht eine basis man kann
sie nicht auf nicht stützen
ich vergleiche es immer mit dem alten
ersten superman film in dem louis lane
vom hochhaus stürzt und superman sie
fängt
und sagt ich hab dich keine sorge und
sie erwidert und wer hat dich so geht es
dem dollar wer stützt ihn sicher nicht
superman und selbst kann der dollar
nicht fliegen
es war einmal gold das die in dollar
stützte aber jetzt hat jeder sein schiff
an die titanic der währungen gebunden
und alle werden gemeinsam untergehen
wenn das vertrauen in den us-dollar
schwindet weil es wahrscheinlich noch
vor 2020 passieren wird wäre das nicht
das erste mal in der geschichte
dann müsst mir zu etwas zurückkehren das
vertrauen schafft und gold schafft
vertrauen die einzige lösung ist die
rückkehr zu einer echten gesunden
währung echtes geld mit echten gegenwert
es muss nicht gold oder silber sein aber
in der vergangenheit kamen
gesellschaften durch versuch und irrtum
allen experimenten zum trotz immer
wieder zu gold und silber zurück
es scheint also nicht die schlechteste
idee zu sein in anbetracht all der
unsicherheit in der heutigen welt
erscheint eine rückkehr zu einer
wirtschaft auf basis von gold warum also
wird über eine derartige rückkehr noch
nicht einmal diskutiert die antwort ist
so einfach wie alarmieren
diejenigen die an der spitze sitzen und
vom pony system profitieren soll nicht
dass es endet viele glauben nun der
goldpreis würde unterdrückt um es als
globales austausch medium weniger
attraktiv zu machen regierungen
versuchen den goldpreis niedrig zu
halten damit der dollar als angemessene
leitwährung für die welt wahrgenommen
wird
der dollar hat diesen status aber
überhaupt nicht verdient da die usa ihn
so schlecht verwalten
drücken wie das gold and i trust action
comedy kurz gotta verfolgen die in ihren
augen gezielte unterdrückung des preises
von gold und silber durch zweifelhafte
methoden
[Musik]
wir haben zwölf jahre lang beweise für
die manipulation des goldpreises
gesammelt bei einem mordfall würde die
jury ohne jeden zweifel auf schuldig
plädieren
aber wir müssen alle beweise und ihre
zusammenhänge immer wieder erklären
der goldpreis wird auf viele art
manipuliert nicht alle sind einfach
nachzuweisen
viele die verkäufe durch zentralbanken
sind jedoch klar verzeichnet zwischen
1999 und 2002 verkaufte die britische
zentralbank törichter weise einen
gewaltigen teil der britischen
goldreserven für durchschnittlich 275
dollar
der erlös wurde in euro und dollar
investiert auch die regierungen von
kanada frankreich der schweiz und
anderen staaten verkauften zu der zeit
ihr gold wir wissen dass die
zentralbanken 400 tonnen gold pro jahr
verkauften
es war die mit abstand jüngste
entscheidung des jahrzehnts und sie
taten es wieder und wieder
heute kostet gold 300 bis 1600 fast 1700
warum habt ihr es also verkauft um den
preis zu drücken
es war koordiniert damit alle weiterhin
den währungen vertrauen
greenspan gestand vor dem kongress dass
sie den goldpreis manipulierten als er
sagte die zentralbanken wären bereit
den wachsenden mengen zu leihen sollte
der preis steigen
sie tat es also schon sollte der
goldpreis steigen bedeutet die
unterdrückung war das ziel die taten es
also schon und er gestand ist dem
kongress gegenüber zentralbanken können
die goldreserven ihrer nationen
natürlich legal veräußern
doch nutzten sie zur unterdrückung des
goldpreises auch dubiose praktiken
einige ermittler behaupten westlichen
zentralbanken hätten ihre goldreserven
an gold banken verliehen
gold banken verkaufen gold mit dem ziel
es später zu einem günstigeren preis
zurückzukaufen
der erlös dieser verkäufe floss in der
vergangenheit auch in us bundesanleihen
haben
das ist an sich zwar kein problem doch
verzeichnen die zentralbanken ihr
eigenes gold und das gold das sie den
gold banken geliehen haben als einen
posten
so kann eine zentralbank zwar behaupten
sie hätte goldreserven in einer gewissen
höhe
doch ein großteil davon kann an gold
banken verliehen sein die dieses gold
womöglich gegen bundesanleihen verkauft
haben
eine möglichkeit der intervention auf
dem goldmarkt ist das verleihen von gold
an sogenannte gold banken die das gold
dann auf dem markt verkaufen
das unterdrückt den preis ebenso wie
direkte verkäufe der zentralbanken
taucht aber nicht in ihren büchern auf
vor ein paar jahren änderte die us
staatskasse gold verzeichnet wird so
dass nun einige forderungen ebenso wie
der goldbestand gemeinsam aufgeführt
werden
sie verbuchen also das was sie
tatsächlich haben und das was ihnen
geschuldet wird als ein und dasselbe was
betrügerischer buchführung gleichkommt
doch wozu all der aufwand zur
unterdrückung des gold und silberpreises
warum bedrohen vier gold- und
silberpreise das conti system gold und
nationale währungen stehen in konkurrenz
zueinander denn gold ist der einzige
konkurrent nationaler währungen gold ist
geld und die währungen sind geldersatz
der stadt gold zirkuliert bei vier
währungen hat die regierung die macht
bei echtem geld die bevölkerung echtes
geld beschränkt die regierung denn sie
kann nur ihre steuereinnahmen ausgeben
die bevölkerung sträubt sich gegen
steuern
aber wenn die regierung einfach geld
leihen und drucken kann fällt der
widerstand weg die regierung kann
einfacher wachsen wenn sie einen etwas
im austausch für nichts verspricht
und genau das tun sie gold schützt die
menschen vor unverantwortlichen
regierungen gold beschenkt regierungen
denn die würden gerne tun was sie wollen
doch gold steht ihnen im weg gold ist
der feind übergriffige regierungen aber
ein freund der freiheit ein schutz des
einzelnen vor der regierung gold
konkurriert mit dem dollar ein hoher
preis bedroht die inflation
es ist ein barometer für die us
wirtschaft aktuell auf höhenflug während
die welt zusammenbricht
es zeigt uns wie schlimm die lage ist
also wollen die wall street und die
regierung mit ihren politikern den preis
unterdrücken
die wall street will nicht dass du zum
münzkontor gehst und gold und
silbermünzen kaufst sie waren die
papiere andrehen die regierung genau so
zusammen mit der wall street
gold im besitz des volkes ist die
kontrolle der regierung
die regierung kann kein geld erschaffen
wenn es gold es sie erschaffen nur
papiergeld aus dem nichts mit diesem
papier geld können sie dann kriege
führen
politisches mittel zum zweck nutzen um
ihre freunde zu bereichern
also kämpfen regierungen schon das ganze
jahrhundert lang gegen gold an
trotz all dieser bemühungen den preis
von gold und silber niedrig zu halten
stieß die nachfrage nach gold und silber
aufgrund der instabilität des marktes
zuletzt drastisch was ein tiefgreifendes
problem der zentralbanken offenbarte
westliche zentralbanken haben nun das
problem dass sie viel gold verkauft
haben um den goldpreis zu unterdrücken
sie werden jetzt von banken außerhalb
dieses ursprünglichen kartells
vorgeführt die mit großem eifer gold
aufkaufen china russland indien
diese ganzen kleineren zentralbanken
abseits des mainstreams die nicht teil
der elite des internationalen
bankenwesens sind sichern sich jetzt
hunderte tonnen davon den goldpreis zu
unterdrücken musste sichtliche
zentralbanken die nationalen
goldreserven verkaufen oder verleihen
da das gold dabei jedoch ihre tresore
nur selten verlässt weiß niemand ob sie
nicht mehr gold verkaufen oder verleihen
als sie tatsächlich habe sollte dem so
sein da diese es eine der größten
betrugsmaschen der weltgeschichte ein
gewaltiger schwindel
doch nicht von einzelnen ausgehend
sondern von ganzen regierungen das
meiste gold der zentralbanken liegt in
der federal reserve new york und der
bank of england bleibt also in ihren
kellern bei internationalen verkäufen
verschieben sie nur ein paar waren von
einem haufen auf den nächsten machen ein
anderes etiketten oder verändern nur
einen register eintrag da sind
allerdings recht kreative register
einträge dabei
und ich glaube nicht dass tatsächlich
alles von dem gold vorhanden ist
das problem bleibt bestehen wenn alle
besonders die großen fische die ihr gold
gleichzeitig geliefert haben wollten wir
das einfach nicht möglich beim meisten
geld ist es so dass jede unsinn mehrfach
verkauft wurde und mehrere personen
meinen es würde ihnen gehört ich sage es
immer wieder wenn man es nicht in die
hand nehmen kann gehört es einen nicht
das spiel muss früher oder später enden
irgendwann wird das physische gold und
silber eingefordert wir sehen das auch
heute standen
der mangel an verantwortlichkeit bei
goldverkäufen westlicher zentralbanken
hat bisher kaum besorgnis erregt wenn
jedoch mehr und mehr goldkäufer
physische lieferungen verlangen werden
die zentralbanken die zu viel verkauft
oder ihre nationalen goldreserven
verliehen haben einen gewaltigen skandal
auslösen
in folge derartiger betrügereien könnten
goldkäufer und einzelpersonen pensions-
oder hedgefonds oder sogar ganze
nationen um milliarden dollar betrogen
es erinnert ein wenig an den murdoch
skandal bei fox in london und den madoff
skandal
die presse ist mit den superreichen und
der politik ins bett gegangen
leider ändert sich immer erst etwas wenn
die bombe geplatzt ist madoff ging hoch
ging hoch gold wird ebenso hoch gehen
mehr noch als diese beiden da es
weltweit das finanzwesen betrifft
[Musik]
die politiker und banker von heute haben
alles verlernt
außer mir geld zu drucken und die
währung aufzublasen
das ist ihr ganzes repertoire
wenn wir uns weiterhin auf sie und ihre
führung bei der lösung von problemen
verlassen
die könnten die etwas anderes erhalten
sie können nichts anderes
die einzige andere möglichkeit wäre die
inflation zu beenden und zu einer
gesunden währung zurückzukehren
aber das wollen sie nicht denn dann
wären sie ihr arbeitslos das system
werde obwohl sich risse im finanzsystem
auftun sind die einzigen
lösungsvorschläge der regierungen
diejenigen die uns der katastrophe immer
näher bringen
zwar kann der einzelne die welt nicht
selbst retten
doch kann man schritte ergreifen um
zumindest sich und seine familie zu
schützen
man kann nicht von einem pony betrüger
verlangen dass er ein ähnliches geschäft
für das kann er nicht
man kann also nicht von den ganzen ponzi
betrügern der regierung verlangen dass
sie die krise auf andere art und weise
lösen sollen
sie wissen ja nicht wie das geht wir
müssen aufhören uns für die lösung
unserer probleme auf die gleichen
menschen mit der gleichen mentalität zu
verlassen wenn die regierungen nicht zum
goldstandard zurückkehren wollen müssen
die bürger das selbst tun
regierungen können so viel fiat geld
erschaffen wie sie wollen dafür ist es
da warum sollte man dem also vertrauen
den politikern dem bürokraten und
zentralbankern wenn man etwas echtes
haben kann etwas mit intrinsischen wert
dass weiterhin selten bleiben wird
gold oder 4
wir beobachten überall auf der welt wie
die menschen erkennen dass gold seinen
wert mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit viel
besser bewahrt als ein stück papier
es geht nicht darum dass der goldpreis
steigt sondern dass der wert des dollars
sinkt die menschliche anstrengung und
kaufkraft bei gold bleibt gleich mit
einer unze kann man heute noch genau so
viel kaufen wie vor 2000 jahren die
gewinnung eine unze gold verschlingt
heute noch genauso viel menschliche
anstrengung wie vor 2000 jahren durch
diese aufwands gleichheit bei der
gewinnung ist gold so stabil
gold ist finanzielle absicherung beim
gold gesetz geht es darum dass man sich
schützen
man muss es haben schon alleine um
durchschlafen zu können
sonst bleibt einem nichts bei
katastrophen wie sie sie schon oft
erlebt haben
wie schützt man sich sonst
das aktuelle finanzsystem mag untergehen
doch jedes chaos bietet auch schon der
zusammenbruch des alten systems könnte
die tür zu großem wohlstand aufstoßen
es ist sicher nicht das ende der welt
vielleicht noch nicht mal von amerika
für viele länder wird es dem beginn
eines aufschwungs markieren da eine
gewaltige last von ihnen genommen wird
die welt wird nicht länger belohnen an
amerika leihen müssen damit wir hier
verbrauchen können ohne zu produzieren
diese unter geil wird der welt gut tun
wir sollten als weltgemeinschaft nicht
fürchten sondern begrüßen die größte
wohlstands verlagerung der geschichte
sein
die globale währungskrise wird eine
größere verlagerung von wohlstand
verursachen als wir sie jene geschichte
beobachten konnten
und zwar plötzlich also ist es auch die
größte chance
millionen von menschen stellen sich
heute die frage was sollte es sein und
sie machen große fortschritte dabei
besonders die junge generation
[Musik]
morgen geht die sonne auf die schon
millionenfach zuvor pendler wachen auf
und fan ins büro um ihr tagewerk zu
verrichten
vor landwirte kümmern sich um die ernte
und bauarbeiter errichten neue
infrastruktur doch wird die welt noch
dieselbe sein
2008 der alte die welt ein weckruf der
größte finanz crash der weltgeschichte
wurde durch die gleichen schlechten
entscheidungen verzögert die ihn
verursacht hatten die gewaltige
bankenrettung erkaufte uns keine lösung
unsere zeit zeit in der die
verantwortlichen einem sterbenden system
die letzten dollar prangen aber
gleichzeitig erhielten diejenigen die
den abgrund kommen sagen die gelegenheit
sich selbst und ihre familien vor dem
bevorstehenden fall zu schützen
diese zeit könnte sich als das
wertvollste aller kürze erweisen
es gibt in der geschichte immer wieder
diese kurzen momente in denen die
absicherungs währung der vergangenen
5000 jahre zeitgleich die wertanlage mit
der größten potenziellen wachstumschance
in sachen kaufkraft ist so etwas erleben
wir gerade geld ist die beste geldanlage
[Gelächter]
man stößt währung abkauft geld und kann
sich später wahrscheinlich sehr viel
mehr davon kaufen
am besten wäre es jedoch wenn die
menschen verantwortung übernehmen und
sich in sachen finanzen informieren wird
das wichtigste ist sich nicht mehr bei
allen entscheidungen von den banken
brokern und anderen leuten leiten zu
lassen und sich für sich selbst stark zu
machen
[Musik]